what if you could make a creature that
was half human half animal what would
you use it for to fly away on to race
what if you could use it to save lives
that's what some scientists are trying
to do by injecting human stem cells into
animal embryos scientists have already
created chimeras they hope this will
help them better understand how diseases
develop in humans but the really big
goal growing customized organs for
patients who need transplants this is
how it works first scientists take an
animal embryo and delete the gene in its
DNA responsible for growing an organ for
example a pancreas then human stem cells
which are cells that can grow into any
organ are inserted into the embryo with
the edited DNA scientists hope the stem
cells will fill in the missing gap in
the modified DNA of the embryo which
could lead to a human pancreas growing
inside the animal that pancreas would be
harvested and transplanted into a human
who needs it that's a big deal when
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world are on waiting lists for organ
transplants imagine farms where organs
are harvested like that saving the lives
of so many humans but don't get too
excited just yet
scientists have edited the genes and
injected human stem cells into animal
embryos but so far the rest is just
theory part of the problem is there's
actually no way just yet to control what
those stem cells would do and here we
come to the line where ethics and
science clash what if human cells make
their way into a pig's brain could that
Pig achieve human consciousness would it
actually be human or part human or still
only an animal what if the stem cells
produce human sperm and eggs in the
chimeras and then those chimeras mate
would they produce a human-like creature
inside an animal these possibilities
make a lot of people very uncomfortable
that might be why so few scientists are
able to work on this research but if
there was a chance that a human animal
chimera could save lives
would you be okay with the consequences